Jack the Ripper was a lady killer in the
worst sense of the word so it only makes
sense that Evie Frye will get to hunt
down history's most notorious serial
killer Jack the Ripper DLC is cutting
its way into Assassin's Creed syndicate
on December 15 the DLC will be available
on ps4 xbox one and pc for Ubisoft's
latest Assassin's Creed title and it
takes place 20 years after the events of
the main game the description reads the
streets of London are filled with fear
and Evie fries on the trail of one of
history's most mysterious killers armed
with some new skills she must
investigate a series of crimes that draw
her deep into the dark underworld of
Victorian London's Whitechapel district
this Jack the Ripper mystery will cost
you 1499 a la carte but it's also
available as part of the game season
pass priced at twenty-nine ninety-nine
making that purchase will also net you
three additional gameplay packs two sets
of gear and weapons and a permanent XP
boost if you're looking for a reason to
return to London for more assassination
action this DLC pack seems like a good
excuse if you're looking for more
information on all upcoming Assassin's
Creed content keep it locked at gamespot
com